>> Can India become a superpower?
I guess I would have two primary responses.
Number one, yes.
In fact, not only can India become a superpower,
it is well on its way
to getting there.
And given the weight of its population, given
its geopolitical
situation, given the resources it has, and
given, belatedly, the
significant improvement it is starting to
see in its governance, and
given the world we live in where it's difficult
to suppress good ideas
and difficult to suppress the expectation
of a population, and given it
being a liberal democracy -- in my mind, it
is absolutely inevitable.
So not only can India become a superpower,
it will definitely become a
superpower.
The second point I would add is becoming a
superpower, I think, in the
future is going to mean very different things
than it has meant in the
past.
And in some ways you could argue that just
the concept of a superpower
is going to become a little irrelevant because
there be 3, 4, 5,
perhaps, economic powers that will anchor
the world.
And if all of them are superpowers, then I'm
not sure any of them is a
superpower in that sense.
Thank you.